- I hum a lot of things to myself
looking like a crazy person. But that's-
- I'm usually humming with a phone kind of
videoing myself, humming.
- That was it.
So I, the Captain Marvel
theme, I was actually out
on a walk and I came up with the theme
and sang it on my phone,
and it's still on my phone.
And that is the Captain Marvel theme.
(gentle music plays)
Hi, Natalie.
Hello. How are you?
- Yeah, great, thank you.
- What did you do when you
found out you were accepted?
- Oh, I was driving along
in the car with my family.
I was with my daughter
and my mom and dad and...
- Did she know what the Academy is?
Your daughter.
- I think they vaguely knew what it was,
but they knew I was
excited about something
so that was nice.
How about you?
- It was the same, you
know, it's a pandemic time
so I was just home and I
found out, it was amazing.
It's such a great honor to
be a part of this community
that we all loved and admired.
I've been watching the Oscars
since I was six years old.
I haven't missed one.
I would wake up at three
in the morning in a stumble
and watch the Oscars.
So for me, just being a
part of this community
and in some small way,
it's been a huge honor.
(Captain Marvel theme plays)
So how did you know music was your thing?
- [Natalie] Well, I guess,
my mom was a music teacher.
My grandma was a violinist,
so I've always been in music
but I think I, it was, I was
about five when I watched ET
and then I remember noticing
the score and hearing it
in my head afterwards.
My sight reading was a bit
terrible, so I would always
make pe-, I'd learn something by ear
and then make some of it up.
So I think that was my
foray into composing.
- I still do that.
- Do you?
(both laugh)
My teacher would be like, that's lovely.
It's not what's on the
page, but. How about you?
When did you decide to
become a film composer?
- Don't think it was really a decision.
I was five years old when
I started the conservatory.
My dad was a violinist
but he had to give it up
to do anything but music.
So kind of lived vicariously through me.
And then I fell in love with films.
I didn't really even
know the film scoring was
a job that people have done, you know?
And as soon as I actually realized, wait,
they're actually people
that get hired to write this
and this is their thing.
I was really, really hooked.
You're classically trained as well.
Did you, do you ever feel
like you wanted to rebel
against just a classical repertoire?
Did you ever go through that
phase or was it just me?
- Oh, no, for sure.
I remember going to music
college and I was learning
the violin and always had this feeling
that I kind of want to be
creating something a bit of,
you know, I'm not just
playing somebody else's music
but I'm really grateful to
have had that experience
and I think it's so useful
to have sat in that position
and to have that kind of skillset.
Yeah. I did a masters in film composing.
I went to film school.
Bringing that love of music
and film together as well,
it's such a brilliant job.
I'm so happy to be doing it.
- I think it's so important to
kind of get to know the rules
so we can break them.
That's what I always would say
because I think a lot of
the classical education
that we get when we are young, I mean,
I hated figured bass
and all of that stuff.
I'm like, where am I
gonna reuse this stuff?
And then you start realizing, you know,
just in terms of voice
leading and, you know,
a lot of the things that we do,
how it becomes automatic.
It's like a emotional, an
intellectual muscle memory.
(Pomp and Marmalade plays)
- [Narrator] Darkest Peru,
a vast unexplored wilderness
shrouded in history.
- And how did you get into film music?
- I had an ex-boyfriend
who did a gap year working
at Abbey Road as a runner.
- Oh, cool.
- [Natalie] So when I was
still at school and I would go
and see him and sneak in
the back of Abbey Road
and Trevor Jones,
recording a League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen
that was,
- Oh wow.
- That was like watching
that being recorded.
And I was just in there
all day, like, oh, wow.
And then Trevor invited
us to the premiere.
So seeing that kind of glitzy
side of Premiere as well,
I think that got me completely hooked and.
- Really? The premieres
are the part that I dread.
I like everything else
before it in the premieres.
I've been a musician my whole life
but what I really loved
was storytelling and films.
I wanted to be a part of it so badly
because it was magic for me
just to see a film come
together from a speck
of an idea to this thing
that we sit and watch
with our popcorn, it's
like, it's incredible.
I think it's pure magic,
no matter the budget,
no matter the process.
I think the fact that anything
that we watch gets made
is a miracle and music was
the language that I knew
that could be a part of,
that could be my
contribution to filmmaking.
- (indistinct)
- I can't.
- Yes, you can.
Actually you just say
here and you throw it out.
- Right. And then I'm sure
they'll happily let us go.
How do they keep finding us?
- You're basically a walking disco ball.
- Oh, I've got really interested
in standup comedy recently.
I'm like reading Judd Apatow's book.
He was talking about how's like this pain
at the beginning of trying
to start the idea off.
And then after a certain point
it starts writing itself.
And it's like, it's always the beginning
for me that's, it's
like, I've got nothing.
I'm staring at a blank page.
When it all starts coming
together and you've got into
the project and it's, you're
watching and you're like, oh,
I know that should be that theme.
And I love that moment
where you've kind of lined
the pieces up and it
feels like it's easier.
I don't know about you.
- You need to like the pain
of creation to do what we do,
I think, right?
For me, a lot of times
it's just right before it.
That's like for Captain
Marvel, I remember I was
in the studio for two days
and 'cause it was already
announced that I was
scoring, and so I was getting
all these messages from people saying,
oh, this theme better be good.
It should be timeless.
It should be so this,
it should be so that.
So I'm like, thank you for the pressure.
So I remember sitting in
the studio for two days just
trying out different things
and not being happy with it.
So in those situations I
actually get out of the studio
and I go for a walk.
There's something about writing a theme,
just humming the theme.
If you're need a tune, a
proper theme for something,
I need to be able to sing it.
- Paul McCartney was saying
for coming up with songs
that if you hum something,
you come up with an idea
and you can remember it the next day.
So you kind of sleep on it as well.
I think if it's got
that sort of durability
that it sticks in your
head for a long time.
'Cause sometimes you can go
back and record something.
And I think if it also
sticks in your head,
it's kind of a good test for it as well.
If that makes any sense.
- Yeah.
I think the next morning test
is a really important one.
- Yeah, there's a trombone group
and my friend filmed them
playing the Loki theme.
And it's just like, that was
that was something I hummed
into my phone.
And now there's, people
associate it with this character
and yeah's they want to
play it in a school band.
- Once you hit the school
band you know you made it.
You know, it's really what it is.
That's the (laughs).
- It's just amazing.
It's so satisfying.
(energetic music plays)
- (whimpers)
(grunts)
- So as composers, we have to
wear different hats sometimes
and we're the musician, we're the writer
and we're the producer.
And can you talk a little
bit about the different roles
that we have?
- [Natalie] I kind of enjoy
all the different parts
of it equally, but I
never enjoy finishing.
I always feel like I want
to keep tweaking this
or maybe I could add some more.
I find it really hard to kind
of reach that cutoff point
where you have to deliver a
cue and stop mixing something.
I think that's the worst
part for me, is letting go.
- Yeah. Letting go. And knowing
when it's enough, right?
I think that's the key.
Like when do you stop adding more?
Yeah, I think that's a pretty
important part of the process.
And I think a lot of times,
deadlines really help with that
because when you know you
have to finish something
by the next day, you
only have that much room
to play around with it.
So that really helps.
- (shouts)
(water splashing)
(calm theme plays)
(oinking)
- If you were to go back to
yes, there's a time machine
and you saw yourself, what would
you tell your younger self?
- I definitely think when I
left film school in early 2000s,
there was a real lack of women
in the industry composing.
I didn't really feel like
I had a place, I kind of,
I was made to feel like
a second class citizen
at that point in time.
I went back to playing
the violin professionally
which in hindsight was
brilliant because, you know,
sitting in the orchestra,
it gives you a lot of skills
and tools and orchestration ideas.
But I wish I'd carried on and, you know,
had some perseverance because, you know,
we are proving that
there is a space for us.
And I think a few years later it,
it's really opened up and the
industry's really changing.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah. I don't know.
What would you say to your younger self?
- I'd say don't worry too much.
It's all gonna be okay.
I, it's still an advice
to myself currently.
I would worry less and
just keep with the flow.
- Yeah. That sounds like good advice
just generally for everyone.
- Yeah. (laughs)
This has been so great.
It's lovely finally meeting you in person.
It's just been such a
pleasure getting to meet
and chat with you.
- Oh, thank you.
It's so exciting to join the academy
and get to meet you.
It's just so many exciting
things all at once.
- Oh, and more to come.
- For you too.
(upbeat music plays)